Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. So Athens came to flourish, and to make manifest how important it is, not just on one level but on all, for everyone in a city to have an equal voice. For the Athenians, while subjects of a tyrant, had been no more proficient in battle than any of their neighbors. But then, once liberated from tyranny, they emerged as supreme by far, proof enough that the downtrodden, since their labors are all in the service of a master, will never willingly pull their weight, whereas free men, because they have a stake in their own exertions, will set to them with relish. So that is the father of history, or the father of lies, depending on whom you believe, Herodotus,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。因此，雅典走向了繁荣，并彰显出一个道理：对于一个城市中的所有人来说，不仅在一个层面，而是在所有层面上都拥有平等的发声权利，是何等的重要。因为雅典人在沦为暴君的臣民时，在战斗中的表现并不比任何邻国更出色。然而一旦从暴政中解放出来，他们便远远脱颖而出，成为了至高无上的存在。这足以证明，那些饱受践踏的人，由于他们的劳动完全是为了服主子服务，因此绝不会心甘情愿地尽职尽责；而自由人则不同，因为他们自己的奋斗与切身利益息息相关，所以会满腔热情地投入其中。这就是历史之父，或者说谎言之父——这取决于你相信谁——希罗多德，
talking about how in 506 BC, the Athenians fought off an attempt by the Spartans and the Thebans, their rivals, to throttle a radical new system of government in its cradle. And that radical new system of government, Tom, was democracy, something that we all now think is splendid, but the Spartans thought it was an absolute waste of space. And the Thebans too. I mean, basically everyone did. And the association of Athens with democracy, I guess it's probably, I mean, it's probably, if you talk to people about ancient Athens, most people would think of it as the birthplace of democracy, and they would see it as a kind of democratic system. And Athens is basically the place where the notion of democracy is born.
在讲述公元前506年，雅典人如何击退了他们的对手斯巴达人和底比斯人企图将一种崭新的激进政体扼杀在摇篮之中的企图。而那个激进的新政体，汤姆，就是民主制度。现在我们所有人都认为这棒极了，但斯巴达人却觉得这简直是一无是处。底比斯人也这么认为。我的意思是，基本上所有人都这么想。雅典与民主制度的联系，我想这大概是……我的意思是，如果你跟别人谈起古雅典，大多数人会认为它是民主的发源地，并会把它看作是一种民主体制。雅典基本上就是孕育民主观念的地方。
But I think that it's a treacherous word because the question is, to what extent does what we mean by democracy map onto what the Athenians meant by democracy? And I think that there is a huge temptation on our part to assume that they're basically the same things. And so we judge the Athenians by our standards. And so the thing that people will always say about Athenian democracy is, well, women didn't have the vote. Foreigners didn't have the vote. Slaves didn't have the vote.
但我觉得这是一个充满陷阱的词，因为问题在于：我们所理解的“民主”，在多大程度上契合了雅典人所理解的“民主”？而且我认为，我们非常容易想当然地认为这两者基本上是一回事。于是，我们便用我们的标准去评判雅典人。因此，人们在谈论雅典民主时，总是会说：瞧，女性没有选举权，外国人没有选举权，奴隶没有选举权。
And underpinning that critique is, I think, the idea that democracy is founded on the idea of rights, that people have rights to votes. And I think that actually the story of how democracy came to be born in Athens and what democracy meant is kind of stranger and weirder than that. And it kind of requires us to try and essentially kind of wipe away our own understanding of what democracy is and try and stand in shoes that are actually very strange. Yeah, because obviously what we do, Tom, is either we say, so the sort of the children's book version of Athens is they're all wrestling, smearing themselves as oil, talking about philosophy and being Democrats, in contrast to the ferocious Spartans. And then what people tend to do when they sort of hit 19 is they say, oh, the Athenians are actually terrible people.
我认为，支撑这种批判的理念是：民主是建立在权利的基础之上的，即人们拥有投票权的权利。但实际上，我认为民主如何在雅典诞生以及民主到底意味着什么的这段历史，要比这更加奇异和诡异。它在本质上要求我们去尝试抹去我们自身对民主的理解，并试着设身处地去代入一种实际上非常奇特的视角。是的，因为显而易见的是，汤姆，我们所做的事情要么是——所以关于雅典的“儿童读物版”叙事是：他们都在摔跤、身上抹着橄榄油、谈论哲学、当民主主义者，这与凶猛的斯巴达人形成了鲜明对比。然后，当人们长到19岁左右时，往往就会说：哦，雅典人其实是一群糟糕透顶的家伙。
They didn't let women vote. So you're either sort of extolling them and raising them to the skies, or you're saying, well, they don't measure up to 21st century standards. And both of those are quite foolish, I would say. Right. So I wrote about this in Persian Fire. And it was one of the things that I wrestled with most intensely, the sense of how alien and strange the ancient world was and how treacherous a language English was for trying to write about it. Because, I mean, you know, you've heard me say I'm a stuck record. I think we bring this kind of Christian idea that every individual being has a kind of value.
他们不让女性投票。所以，你要么是在吹捧他们、把他们捧上天，要么就是在说：嗯，他们根本不符合21世纪的标准。我要说的是，这两种做法都相当愚蠢。没错。所以我在《波斯之火》（Persian Fire）一书中写过这一点。这也是我极力纠结的事情之一，那就是古代世界是多么的异质和陌生，以及用英语去书写这段历史是多么充满陷阱。因为，我的意思是，你知道的，你听过我说过，我就是个老唱片。我认为我们带着这种基督教的观念，即每一个独立的个体生命都具有某种价值。
And that's essentially what underpins our ideal of democracy. This idea that- Has an equal value, right? Right. But for the Athenians, it's radically different. And so I think the best way, in a sense, to get a sense of how radically different and the challenges of understanding exactly what was going on is to give the story that the Athenians themselves came to understand.
而这本质上正是支撑我们民主理想的基石。这种观念——具有同等的价值，对吧？没错。但对雅典人来说，情况有着根本的不同。因此，我认为要想理解这种根本的不同在哪里，以及理解当时究竟发生了什么所面临的挑战，最好的办法就是讲述雅典人自己所理解的那段历史。
So this is the story that an Athenian, say, by the fourth century BC would have told about how democracy came into existence over the course of the 6th century and into the 5th century. So just before you do that, give us the very, very, for those people who are not familiar with ancient Greece, the broadest possible sort of context. So Athens was founded... Well, I'm going to be coming to this because it is a story that in the Athenian understanding goes right the way back to the beginning of the appearance of human beings. So the story that the Athenians tell is that the goddess Athena, the god of war, the god of domestic crafts, the goddess of wisdom, the great patron of heroes, that her brother, Hephaestus, who is the smith, the artificer, this lame blacksmith, he is aroused by her.
所以，这就是一个雅典人——比如生活在公元前4世纪的雅典人——会讲述的故事：关于民主如何在公元前6世纪到公元前5世纪期间逐渐诞生。所以在你讲这个之前，能先为那些对古希腊不熟悉的听众，提供一个最大、最宏观的背景吗？所以雅典建城……嗯，我马上就会讲到这一点，因为在雅典人的理解中，这是一个可以一直追溯到人类出现之初的故事。因此，雅典人讲述的故事是这样的：雅典娜女神，作为战神、家庭手工艺之神、智慧女神以及英雄们的伟大保护神，她的兄弟赫菲斯托斯——也就是铁匠、工匠、那个跛脚的铁匠——被她激起了欲望。
He reaches for her, essentially to try and rape her. Athena brushes him off, but not before, in his excitement, he has left a physical mark on Athena, expressive of his excitement and she takes a scrap of wool and she she wipes the met phyces mess off her thigh and she drops it down onto attica right and in greek uh the scrap of wool is called erion and the earth is called Chthon. And so when from this discarded Tosrag, a human being with the tail of a snake emerges, he's called Erechtheus. So kind of fusing this idea of the scrap of wool and the earth. In some way, there's a kind of divine origin here, but it's also bread of the earth. And Erechtheus is seen as the founder of the Athenian people, and his body is entombed within the Acropolis. And so Erechtheus in some way is the kind of the archetype of the Athenian people.
他向她伸出手，本质上是试图强暴她。雅典娜一把推开了他，但在他激动之余，却在雅典娜身上留下了身体上的痕迹，这表达了他的冲动。雅典娜随手扯下一团羊毛，擦掉了大腿上的秽物，并把它扔到了阿提卡（Attica）的土地上。没错，在希腊语中，“羊毛团”被称为 erion，而“大地”被称为 chthon。因此，从这个被丢弃的羊毛团中，诞生了一个长着蛇尾的人，他名叫厄瑞克透斯（Erichthonius）。这实际上融合了羊毛团和大地这两个概念。从某种意义上说，这里有一种神圣的起源，但同时他也是大地孕育的产物。厄瑞克透斯被视为雅典人民的始祖，他的遗体被安葬在卫城（Acropolis）内。因此，从某种程度上说，厄瑞克透斯就是雅典人民的原型。
And he has a kind of weird relationship to Athena. Athena, who is a virgin, isn't exactly his mother, but in some way is complicit in the process by which he has come to spring from the earth. And that's why the Athenians said it was Erechtheus who had instituted this great festival, the Athenaea, in honor of Athena, a great procession going up to the Acropolis. Now, in some way that's never entirely explained by the athenians they think that they share in this quality of coming from the soil from the kthonos and so they call it autochthony the idea that they have sprung from the earth and so in that sense the athenian people the athenian demos are like the wheat or the olives
他与雅典娜有着一种奇特的关系。作为处女的雅典娜虽然严格来说不是他的母亲，但在他从大地中跃出的这个过程中，某种程度上却是同谋。正因如此，雅典人说正是厄瑞克透斯为纪念雅典娜创立了这盛大的节日——雅典娜节（Athenaea），这是一场前往卫城的盛大游行。如今，雅典人从未完全解释清楚的是，他们认为自己拥有这种源自土壤、源自 chthonos 的特质，因此他们称之为“本土诞生”（autochthony）——即他们是从大地中破土而出的观念。所以在这种意义上，雅典人民、雅典的德莫斯（demos，公民群体）就像是小麦、橄榄树、
or the vines or the figs, that they literally spring from the earth. The Athenians claimed, although it was contested by other peoples in Greece, that they were the oldest people in Greece and indeed the oldest people in the world, and that they are all born equally from the earth. What the Athenians called it, so gonia, sprung equally, I say is equally. And the most famous articulation of this comes from Pericles in his speech as recorded by Thucydides, where he says of the Athenians that the same ethnic stock, generation after generation, the same people, they have always lived in this, our native land. And it is they, by virtue of their qualities, who have bequeathed it to us, a country eternally free. And so this idea that the Athenian love of freedom, that the Athenian sense that they are all in it together, is somehow tied in with the
葡萄藤或是无花果，他们是字面意义上从大立体中破土而出的。雅典人声称——尽管这遭到希腊其他民族的争辩——他们是希腊最古老的民族，实际上也是世界上最古老的民族，并且他们都是平等地从大天生中诞生的。雅典人称之为 gonia，即“同等破土而出”，我说的就是“平等”。对此最著名的阐述来自伯里克利（Pericles）在修昔底德（Thucydides）所记录的演讲中。他在演讲中谈到雅典人时说，他们拥有相同的血统，代代相传，都是同一个族群，一直居住在我们这片祖祖辈辈的土地上。正是他们凭借自身的品质，将这片永远自由的土地留传给我们。因此，雅典人对自由的热爱、雅典人认为他们休戚与共的意识，在某种程度上与
fact that they uniquely among the Greek people have sprung from the earth, that that ancestry has never been diluted. It's a really fundamental part of how the Athenians see themselves. Obviously, Athens didn't really come into being that way without being too sceptical. So are they telling this story from the very beginning or is this a story created later on? So we will come to this. Oh, I'm jumping ahead. So you're absolutely right to have fixed on that, but let's just keep that in mind. So you have this guy, Erechtheus. He's kind of first of a line of kings. Probably most people who have any interest in Greek mythology will remember the name of another king, Aegeus, who he is for us, but as a key figure in their constitutional history. So Theseus does two crucial things, the Athenians think. First of all,
这样一个事实密不可分：在希腊各民族中，唯独他们是从大地上破土而出的，他们的血统从未被稀释过。这是雅典人如何看待自己的一项极其根本的内容。显而易见，雅典并不是真的那样凭空诞生的——如果不那么过于怀疑的话。那么，他们是从一开始就在讲这个故事，还是后来编造出来的故事？我们稍后会讲到这一点。哦，我扯得太远了。所以你抓住这一点绝对是正确的，但让我们先把这一点记在心中。所以你有了这个叫厄瑞克透斯的家伙。他是历代国王中的第一位。对希腊神话感兴趣的人大概都会记得另一个国王的名字——埃勾斯（Aegeus），他之于我们而言是……但在他们的宪政史上，另一个关键人物是忒修斯（Theseus）。忒修斯做了两件至关重要的事情，雅典人是这样认为的。首先，
he gets all the various peoples of Attica and he joins them together so that they all become citizens of Athens. And so that festival, the Athenaea that Erechtheus had instituted, under Theseus, it becomes the Panathenaia. Everybody, so pan meaning all, everybody across the whole of Attica become Athenian citizens. And Athens is very, very unusual among Greek cities in having so vast a citizen body. Attica is huge compared to Sparta or Argos or Corinth. Athens is a city. I mean, it's not so much polis, a city, as an entire people, an ethnos. And that's what makes it distinctive. And the Athenians say that Theseus is the key figure in this kind of process. The other thing that the Athenians say is that it
他将阿提卡的各个部族汇聚到一起，把他们联合起来，使他们全都成为了雅典公民。因此，由厄瑞克透斯创立的那个雅典娜节，在忒修斯的主导下，变成了泛雅典娜节（Panathenaia）。所有人——“pan”的意思就是全体——整个阿提卡的全体民众都成为了雅典公民。在希腊城邦中，雅典极其特殊，拥有如此庞大的公民群体。与斯巴达、阿尔戈斯（Argos）或科林斯（Corinth）相比，阿提卡是巨大的。雅典不仅是一个城邦。我的意思是，与其说它是一个 polis（城邦），不如说它是一个完整的民族，一个 ethnos（族群）。正是这一点让它与众不同。雅典人说，忒修斯正是这一进程中的关键人物。雅典人还说，
is Theseus who founds the democracy, who founds a system in which the demos have, kratos, have power. So Theseus is the founder of these two things that make athens distinctive the vastness of its citizen body yeah and the fact that it has a democracy cranky that that eclipses any sort of interaction with minotaurist doesn't it it absolutely does yes it absolutely does right so that's theseus and then you have the the period of the trojan war and then after the trojan war you have the period of the Trojan War. And then after the Trojan War, you have this period of great convulsion where supposedly the descendants of Heracles come down in an enormous force, the ancestors of people called the Dorians, and they become the masters of most of Greece. But the one place that doesn't succumb to these invasions is Athens. So they maintain their independence. They maintain their autochthonous descent, so they say.
正是忒修斯创立了民主制，创立了一个让“德莫斯”（demos）拥有“克拉托斯”（kratos，即权力）的体制。因此，忒修斯是让雅典脱颖而出的这两大特征的奠基人：一是庞大的公民群体，二是拥有民主制。天哪，这简直盖过了任何与牛头怪的神话互动，对吧？绝对是的，没错，绝对是的。好吧，这就是忒修斯，然后是特洛伊战争时期，接着在特洛伊战争之后……特洛伊战争之后，你迎来了一个巨大的动荡时期。据称，赫拉克勒斯的后代以庞大的兵力南下，也就是被称为多利亚人（Dorians）的祖先，他们成为了希腊大部分地区的统治者。然而，唯一没有屈服于这些入侵的地方就是雅典。因此，他们维持了独立。按照他们的说法，他们保持了本土诞生的血统。
So Athens stays kind of inviolate, but moving into, let's say, the 9th, the 8th, the 7th centuries BC, Athens is a backwater. It's backwards, it's parochial, and you have the sense of a kind of a division between aristocracy and the vast mass of people who are basically on the verge of becoming peasants or serfs. That is the marker really of its backwardness relative to other cities like Argos or Corinth, which are kind of much more go-getting, much more mercantile. Backward, it's divided. It's like modern day New York. Yeah. And it's run by self-proclaimed masters of the universe. Well, there you go. Yes. Who are actually called Eupatrids, so people who are well-born. Right. And interestingly, these are people who claim kind of foreign descent often. So they're not buying into the autochthony. They're saying that they come from other cities
所以雅典在某种程度上保持了完整。但是，进入公元前9世纪、第8世纪、第7世纪时，雅典却成了一个偏远落后的小地方。它既落后又狭隘，并且你能够感受到贵族阶层与广大底层民众之间存在着一种鸿沟，这些人基本上处于沦为农奴或苦工的边缘。这确实标志着它相对于阿尔戈斯或科林斯等其他更加进取、更加商业化的城邦而言的落后。它落后且分裂。它就像现代的纽约。没错。而且它是由自封的“宇宙主宰”统治的。好吧，这倒也是。是的。这些人其实被称为尤帕特里德（Eupatrids），也就是出身名门的人。没错。有趣的是，这些人往往声称自己拥有某种外来血统。所以他们并不买账“本土诞生”的说法。他们说自己来自其他城邦，
and they are oppressive and they're domineering. And there is no sense at all, really, of the Athenians as a single united people. And the measure of this is that the end of the 7th, beginning of the 6th century BC, they get into a war with a much smaller city called Megara. And they're fighting over the island of Salamis, which is kind of midway between Athens and Megara. And the Athenians lose, and it's completely humiliating. It's like Premier League team being knocked out of the FA Cup by some kind of minnow. Aston Villa humbled by Warsaw. That kind of thing, yes. And basically, the Athenians seem to have decided that enough was enough, that this was embarrassing, that something had to be done. And they're encouraged to do this
并且他们具有压迫性和专横性。人们根本感觉不到雅典人是一个单一的团结民族。而这方面的衡量标准是：在公元前7世纪末到公元前6世纪初，他们与一个名叫墨伽拉（Megara）的小得多的城邦陷入了战争。他们在争夺萨拉米斯岛（Salamis），该岛位于雅典和墨伽拉之间。结果雅典人战败了，这简直奇耻大辱。这就好比英超球队在足总杯中被某种鱼腩球队淘汰了一样。阿斯顿维拉被华沙（球队）羞辱。差不多就是那种感觉，是的。基本上，雅典人似乎觉得够了，这太令人尴尬了，必须得做点什么。而促使他们采取行动的是
by the appearance in the streets of Athens of spectral figures, kind of portents of doom, it seems. And so they turn to a man who we have already mentioned on The Rest is History. Listeners to our episode on Atlantis may remember Solon. Oh, yes, the lawgiver. Who supposedly gets told the story of Atlantis by the Egyptian priests. And the reason that he's in Egypt is that he's doing a tour for 10 years because he has basically reformed Athens. And he has then left Athens to allow his laws to bed in and so that it won't seem like he's done the laws purely for his own benefit.
雅典街头出现了一些幽灵般的人物，这似乎是不祥之兆。于是，他们转向了一个我们在《历史的余烬》中已经提到过的人。收听过我们关于亚特兰蒂斯（Atlantis）节目的听众可能还记得梭伦（Solon）。哦，是的，那个立法者。传说亚特兰蒂斯的故事就是埃及祭司讲给他的。而他之所以在埃及，是因为他在进行为期10年的游历，因为他基本上重组了雅典。然后他离开了雅典，好让他的法律得以稳固实施，这样就不会让人觉得他制定法律纯粹是为了谋取私利。
So he becomes what is called an archon, the kind of leading magistrate in Athens in 594. And he is remembered by the Athenians as the man who basically, he makes the Athenians equal before the law. So previously it had all been done in custom. Solon puts it down as laws that both rich and poor are equally children of, the phrase is, the holy land of Athena. And this is remembered by the Athenians as a revitalization of their democracy. But the reality is slightly, redounds perhaps slightly less to Solon's credit. He is basically, I mean, he's a kind of centrist.
因此，他在公元前594年成为了所谓的“执政官”（archon），即雅典的首席行政长官。雅典人铭记他是那个基本上让雅典人在法律面前实现平等的人。在此之前，一切都是按照习俗行事的。梭伦将其写入了法律，富人和穷人同样都是——用他的话说——“雅典神圣土地”的儿女。雅典人将此铭记为他们民主制度的复兴。但现实情况其实稍微……或许对梭伦的赞誉要稍微打点折扣。他基本上……我的意思是，他是一个中间派。
He's a centrist dad. You would love him, Tom. Yeah, he's my kind of guy, I guess. Yeah. He could be a guest on our sister podcast where they whitter about politics. Yes, exactly. He'd be very restless politics kind of guy. So essentially, he's trying to balance the interests of the rich and the poor. He's not trying to dissolve the rich into the masses of Ademos. He's trying to balance the interests of the rich and the poor. He's not trying to dissolve the rich into the masses of Ademos. He's trying to preserve the ordinary Athenians from exploitation, but he's also trying to keep the elites in the kind of position of authority that they've always had. So we have kind of things that he wrote, kind of maxims, poems, scraps of poetry.
他是一个中间派老爹。你会喜欢他的，汤姆。是的，我想他确实是我会喜欢的类型。没错。他可以去我们的姊妹播客节目当嘉宾，那里的主持人们整天喋喋不休地讨论政治。是的，没错。他绝对是那种对政治局势坐立不安的人。所以本质上，他在试图平衡富人和穷人的利益。他并不是试图将富人阶层解散并融入德莫斯的群众中。他在试图平衡富人和穷人的利益。他并不是试图将富人阶层解散并融入德莫斯的群众中。他试图保护普通雅典人免受剥削，但同时也试图让精英阶层保持他们一直以来所拥有的那种权威地位。所以我们有一些他写的东西，比如座右铭、诗歌、零星的诗句。
So one of them is that envied for their wealth, though they were, I sought to preserve the powerful from the hatred of the oppressed. Taking my stand, I used my strong shield to protect both sides of the class divide, allowing neither to gain an advantage over the other that would be unjust. So that's basically what the conservatives are doing in the 19th century, right? I mean, into the 20th century, it's this idea that you best preserve the power of the elites by folding the masses into it. Yeah, it's very Disraelian. So very Disraelian. The reason that the rich buy into this isn't only because they can recognize that it's in their own interest, that Solon has a point, but also that the enfranchisement of large
其中一条是这样的：尽管他们因财富而遭人嫉妒，但我仍寻求保护当权者免受被压迫者的仇恨。我挺身而出，用我坚固的盾牌保护阶级鸿沟的两端，不让任何一方获得对另一方不公正的优势。所以，这基本上就是19世纪保守派在做的事情，对吧？我的意思是，直到20世纪，这都是这样一种观念：你通过把大众纳入学理来最好地维系精英的权力。是的，这非常符合迪斯雷利（Disraelian）的风格。非常迪斯雷利。富人之所以买账，不仅是因为他们认识到这符合他们自身的利益，梭伦说得有道理，还因为对大量
numbers of people will give them a larger citizen body and thereby enable them to defeat Megara, which is what they promptly do. As I say, it's a kind of very centrist approach. But the consequence of this does seem to be that Solon, by guaranteeing liberty, freedom from enslavement, and a kind of legal recourse against the oppression of the rich, that he is kind of seeding quite important ideas that will start to grow and grow over the decades that follow. But at the same time, he is absolutely affirming that the rich have exclusive right to the magistracies, that it's their job to run the city. And so this is the kind of the balance that he's tried to strike. And because he's done that, basically, Athens remains the plaything of the Eupatrids,
民众赋权将为他们提供更庞大的公民群体，从而使他们能够击败墨伽拉，而他们也确实立刻这样做了。正如我所说，这是一种非常中间派的方法。但这样做的后果似乎是，梭伦通过保障自由、摆脱奴隶制的自由以及针对富人压迫的法律诉求，实际上播下了相当重要的种子，这些种子在随后的几十年里将不断生根发芽。但与此同时，他绝对肯定了富人对各行政长官职位的专属权利，即治理城市是他们的工作。所以这就是他试图达到的平衡。正因为他做到了这一点，基本上，雅典依然是尤帕特里德们、
of the great families. Because their power has been preserved by this arrangement. Exactly. So there are various aristocratic dynasties that trace their origins a long, long way back, back to the mythical origins of the city. That's why they're well-bred, or they claim ancestry from foreign heroes. And these are figures who, in the decades that follow Solon's reforms, remain absolutely domineering. And there are probably three who play the key role. One of these is a family called the Alkmaionids, and they trace their descent from a guy called Megacles, who had saved Athens from a coup.
那些大贵族家族的玩物。因为他们的权力通过这种安排得以保留。完全正确。因此，有各种各样的贵族王朝，其渊源可以追溯到非常非常久远的过去，一直追溯到这座城市的神秘起源。这就是为什么他们出身高贵，或者他们声称自己是外来英雄的后代。在梭伦改革之后的几十年里，这些人物依然具有绝对的统治力。其中可能起关键作用的有三大家族。其中之一是一个名叫阿尔克迈翁（Alkmaionids）的家族，他们自称是墨伽利斯（Megacles）的后代，后者曾将雅典从一场政变中拯救出来。
An Olympic hero had come back from the games and had occupied the Acropolis and basically tried to seize power in the city. He gets put under siege, starves, negotiates a surrender, comes down into a place of sanctuary where he's met by Megacles, and Megacles kills him and all his followers. This is an absolute desecration. Megacles could argue that he saved the city from a despotism, but his opponents say he has committed sacrilege. If he's not punished for this, then Athens will come under a curse because he's broken his word. And there's kind of 30 years of kind of legal maneuvering, a bit like, I guess, people trying to bring down Trump, law cases. And eventually after 30 years, the Alkmaunids get exiled. The whole dynasty get exiled. And in exile, they continue to flourish. So Alkmaun himself, who gives his name to the dynasty, he becomes a big pal with Croesus, as in richest Croesus, the King of Lydia, by word for fabulous wealth. And Croesus says to Alcmaon, you can go into my treasury and
当时，一位奥林匹克英雄从运动会归来，占领了卫城，并基本上企图夺取城市的政权。他陷入围困、忍饥挨饿、谈判投降，来到了一个避难所，在那里遇到了墨伽利斯，结果墨伽利斯将他和他的所有追随者全部杀害。这简直是对圣地的亵渎。墨伽利斯可以辩称他把城市从专制中拯救了出来，但他的反对者却说他犯下了滔天大罪。如果他不因此受罚，那么雅典就会遭受诅咒，因为他违背了誓言。随之而来的是大约30年的法律角力，有点像——我想——人们试图扳倒特朗普的那些法律诉讼。最终在30年之后，阿尔克迈翁家族被放逐了。整个王朝都被流放了。而在流放期间，他们继续繁荣发展。因此，赋予该王朝名字的阿尔克迈翁本人，与克罗伊索斯（Croesus）——也就是“富得流流油的克罗伊索斯”、吕底亚国王（寓意极度富有）——成了好朋友。克罗伊索斯对阿尔克迈翁说，你可以走进我的宝库，
you can have as much gold as you can carry. So what Alcmaon does is he gets some very, very wide boots and kind of puts on a woman's gown and he just stuffs himself. So he comes out looking like the Michelin man with gold dust. And this is the making of the Alcmaonids. They're now fabulously wealthy, but they're still in exile. Then still back in Athens, you have a dynasty called the Butads who claim descent from the brother of Erechtheus,
你可以带走你能拿得动的所有黄金。阿尔克迈翁想出的办法是，他穿上非常非常宽大的靴子，套上女人的长袍，把自己塞得满满当当的。他走出来时，金尘满身，看起来就像米其林轮胎人一样。阿尔克迈翁家族就这样发迹了。他们现在富可敌国，但仍然流亡在外。当时雅典还有一个名为布塔代的家族，他们自称是埃雷克透斯的兄弟的后代，
the snake-tailed kind of son of Athena, kind of not. And because of this, they claim, they have a kind of very proprietary claim to the Acropolis,
也就是雅典娜那个半人半蛇的儿子，又好像不是。正因如此，他们宣称自己对卫城拥有某种特殊的专属所有权，
which is the great center, not just of Athens, but of the whole of Attica. Because you do have these kind of mountains in Attica with valleys and all the valleys, no matter where they are, they all kind of impinge on the Acropolis. So it's the great kind of center for not just the people living within the city of Athens, but the whole of Attica. And so the Butads by, you know, claiming that they
卫城不仅是雅典的伟大中心，也是整个阿提卡地区的中心。因为阿提卡确实有那种带山谷的山脉，无论这些山谷在哪里，它们最终都汇集到卫城。所以，这里不仅是居住在雅典城内的人民的伟大中心，也是整个阿提卡的中心。因此，布塔代家族通过宣称他们
have a kind of ancestral hold on it, you know, I mean, that gives them absolutely pole position. So it's the Butads who really start to develop the Acropolis. They're the ones who seem to have built this great ramp that goes up to the summit, which is still there to this day, that Taurus will go up if they're going to see the Parthenon. And then there's a third family who are a guy called Persistratus and his descendants, the Persistratids. And he is a guy who stages three coups over the course of his life, trying to make himself what the Greeks called a tyrannos, a tyrant, somebody who has supreme control over the city. And to begin with, he is a kind of pawn in the rivalry between the
对卫城拥有某种祖传的控制权，这无疑让他们占据了绝对的统治地位。正是布塔代家族开始着手开发卫城。他们似乎修建了通往山顶的宏伟坡道，至今犹存，如果游客去看帕台农神庙，就会走这条坡道。然后是第三个家族，由一个叫庇西特拉图及其后代庇西特拉图家族组成。他这个人一生发动了三次政变，企图让自己成为希腊人所说的“僭主”，即独裁者，一个对城市拥有最高控制权的人。一开始，他是两者之间争权夺利的棋子……
Butads and the Arminids. He's kind of Tom Wamsgams. He's a kind of nobody who gradually worms his way in, marries, gets stabbed in the back, stabs other people in the back, until finally, with his third attempt at a coup, he strikes lucky, he defeats his enemies, and he established himself as the master of Athens. Tom, I want to go on record and just say, I think we should have far more Tom Wamsgans references on this podcast. Okay. So people who haven't heard Succession, sorry, but those of you who have, you'll know the reference. So what this whole kind of episode illustrates is that for the aristocratic families,
布塔代家族和阿尔克迈翁家族。他有点像汤姆·沃姆斯甘。他是个无名小卒，通过钻营、结婚、背后捅刀、给别人背后捅刀，最后在第三次发动政变时运气爆棚，击败了敌人，成为了雅典的主人。汤姆，我想正式说一句，我认为我们在这个播客里应该多引用一些汤姆·沃姆斯甘的梗。好吧。所以没听过《继承之战》的人很抱歉，但听过的人就会懂这个梗。所以整个这一集所表明的是，对于贵族家族来说，
it's kind of a zero-sum game. You're either in charge or you're in exile. And it's very, very difficult to attain any stability. And this is true even for Peisistratus once he's made himself tyrant. He has to balance kind of various interests. So he has to put out feelers even to the Almanids. So the Almanids are allowed back into Athens on the assumption that they will back Pe Pisistratus. But he's also doing what, of course, say Peron would be the kind of classic example. He's a kind of Peronist. He's having to keep the masses in order.
这就像是一场零和博弈。你要么掌权，要么流亡。要获得任何稳定性都非常非常困难。即使对庇西特拉图来说也是如此，一旦他成为了僭主。他必须平衡各种利益。所以他甚至向阿尔克迈翁家族抛出了橄榄枝。阿尔克迈翁家族被允许返回雅典，前提是他们支持庇西特拉图。但他也在做的事，当然，比如庇隆就是一个典型的例子。他有点像庇隆主义者。他必须维持大众的秩序。
He's having to give them treats. So he builds some kind of great buildings. So he does a huge Temple of Zeus. He builds this great kind of central square in the middle of Athens, the Agora. So a populist to some degree. He's absolutely a populist. Yeah. He institutes a series of dramas in celebration of Dionysus, which will become the great festivals
他必须给他们一些甜头。所以他建造了一些宏伟的建筑。他修建了一座巨大的宙斯神庙，在雅典市中心建造了一个宏伟的中央广场，即阿戈拉。所以在某种程度上他是个民粹主义者。他绝对是个民粹主义者。是的。他发起了一系列为了庆祝狄奥尼索斯而举办的戏剧活动，这些活动将成为伟大的节日，
of tragedy and comedy for which Athens in due course will become famous. And he bribes the other members of the elites with various magistracies and so on. But the whole thing remains incredibly rickety. Peisistratus is very good at playing this game in a kind of tom wamsgan style yeah he's able to uphold his power and dies in his bed but he has two sons um hipparchus and hippias who kind of share the tyranny between them which simply makes the system even more rickety so actually he's logan roy and they're Kendall and Roman. Isn't that right? Yeah, a bit. Yes, a bit. And the measure of how unstable it is, is firstly that the Alkmanis get sent back into exile. And the leader of the Alkmanis by this point is a guy called Cleisthenes. So he gets kicked back out. And then Hipparchus gets assassinated, not by someone proclaiming
雅典日后正是凭借这些悲剧和喜剧而闻名于世。他用各种官职等好处来收买精英阶层的其他成员。但整个体制依然极其脆弱。庇西特拉图非常擅长以汤姆·沃姆斯甘的风格来玩这场游戏，是的，他能够巩固自己的权力并善终，但他有两个儿子，希帕库斯和希皮亚斯，他们共同分担僭主统治，这使得体制变得更加脆弱。所以实际上他是洛根·罗伊，而他们是肯德尔和罗曼。对吗？是的，有点像。是的，有点。衡量这种不稳定性的标准是，首先阿尔克迈翁家族再次被流放。而此时阿尔克迈翁家族的领袖是一个叫克里斯提尼的人。所以他又被赶了出去。然后希帕库斯被刺杀了，不是被一个宣称
a love of liberty or anything like that, but because he'd been caught up in a lover's tiff. He'd seduced this guy who was the boyfriend of another guy. And so the two people who've been offended by this murder him. So this leaves Hippias, who by this point is in a very tyrannical mood in the modern sense. He becomes increasingly oppressive. And so Cleisthenes, who's kind of sniffing around like a jackal on the margins of Attica, recognizes that he has an opportunity here to overthrow Hippias. So he launches an invasion and that fails. But Cleisthenes isn't going to give up.
热爱自由或类似信仰的人杀死，而是因为他卷入了一场情场纠纷。他勾引了另一个男人的男友。因此，受到冒犯的两个人谋杀了埃庇帕库斯。这留下了希皮亚斯，此时他正处于现代意义上的暴虐情绪中。他变得越来越暴虐。于是克里斯提尼像豺狼一样在阿提卡的边缘窥探，意识到自己在这里有一个推翻希皮亚斯的绝佳机会。于是他发动了一次入侵，但失败了。不过克里斯提尼并没有放弃。
And so he pulls a brilliant stunt. He's got all this gold that he's inherited from Alcmaun, and he's been lavishing a lot of this on Delphi, the home of Apollo, the god of prophecy. What he seems to have done is offered a bribe to Apollo to tell every Spartan emissary who came to Delphi that Sparta had to overthrow Hippias and free the Athenians. This is a problem for the Spartans because they're actually allies of Hippias. free the Athenians. This is a problem for the Spartans because they're actually allies of Hippias. But Apollo keeps saying, go and free the Athenians, go and free the Athenians, go and free the Athenians. Eventually, the Spartan king, Cleomenes,
于是他使出了一招绝妙的计谋。他拥有从阿尔克迈翁那里继承来的全部黄金，并且把其中的大部分都挥霍在了德尔斐——也就是预言之神阿波罗的圣地。他似乎做的是向阿波罗行贿，让阿波罗对来到德尔斐的每一个斯巴达使者说，斯巴达必须推翻希皮亚斯，解放雅典人。这对斯巴达人来说是个问题，因为他们实际上是希皮亚斯的盟友。但阿波罗不断地说，去解放雅典人，去解放雅典人，去解放雅典人。最终，斯巴达国王克里昂米尼
decides that this is what he'd better do. In 510, he marches on Athens. Hippias gets bottled up on the Acropolis. He surrenders. He gets sent into exile. And Athens is faced with the prospect of what is going to happen next. And basically, there seem to be two options because Cleomenes and Cleisthenes, these two people who have combined to end the tyranny, have very different visions for what Athens should be. So Cleomenes wants Athens to be basically a client state of Sparta under the thumb of the Spartans. But that's not what Cleisthenes wants at all. Cleisthenes wants to set Athenian freedom on very, very solid foundations. And it's evident that while he's been in exile, Cleisthenes has been thinking
决定这才是他最好该做的事。公元前510年，他率军进军雅典。希皮亚斯被围困在卫城上。他投降了。他被流放了。雅典面临着接下来会发生什么的前景。基本上，似乎有两个选择，因为克里昂米尼和克里斯提尼这两个联合终结僭主统治的人，对雅典应该成为什么样有着截然不同的愿景。克里昂米尼希望雅典基本上成为斯巴达的附属国，受斯巴达人的控制。但克里斯提尼根本不这么想。克里斯提尼希望将雅典的自由建立在非常非常坚实的基础上。很显然，在流亡期间，克里斯提尼一直在深入思考
a good deal about how this should be done. And essentially, his plan is that the mass of the Athenian people should be given a stake in the running of the city that would have two effects. Firstly, it would further embed their sense of loyalty to Athens and their willingness to, because they now have skin in the game, they are now presumably more willing to fight for it. But the other thing he thinks is that by doing this, it will reduce the stakes for him and for other aristocrats. Because up to this point, failure in this kind of game for political supremacy is terrible. You win or you die, you go into exile or whatever. But if you, as an aristocrat, come to be dependent, say, on the votes of the mass of your fellow citizens, then you can lose, but you're not going to go into exile. And so there's something there
这应该如何实现。基本上，他的计划是让广大的雅典人民在城市的运营中占有一席之地，这将产生两个效果。首先，这会进一步巩固他们对雅典的忠诚感以及他们为之奋斗的意愿，因为他们现在有了切身利益，他们现在大概更愿意为之战斗了。但另一件他认为会发生的事是，通过这样做，将降低他和其它贵族所面临的赌注。因为在此之前，在争夺政治统治权的这种博弈中，失败是极其可怕的。要么赢，要么死，要么流放等等。但如果你作为一个贵族，开始依赖广大同胞公民的选票，那么你可能会输，但你不会被流放。所以这其中也有适合
for the aristocracy as well as for the mass of the people. And so this is what he is looking to institute. But Cleomenes doesn't like this at all. And so there is a breakdown in relations between the two men. And this opens up a chance for other aristocrats to get up to their kind of traditional tricks. And the focus for this comes to be a guy called Isagoras who basically sidles up to cleomenes and says look if you back me over cleisthenes um i'll let you sleep with my wife so he pimps his wife it's said to cleomenes um and in return you know you back me uh and i'll run the city for you so cleisthenes finds himself under threat both from cleomenes and from isagoras and And so he ups the game. And so in 507, he openly turns for support to the mass of the people. He basically proposes to them this kind
贵族以及广大民众的部分。这就是他着手建立的制度。但克里昂米尼一点也不喜欢这样。因此，两人之间的关系破裂了。这也为其他贵族大搞传统伎俩创造了机会。而这其中的焦点是一个名叫伊萨戈拉斯的人，他基本上走到克里昂米尼身边说，听着，如果你支持我取代克里斯提尼，嗯，我让你和我妻子睡。所以他把妻子出卖给克里昂米尼，据说如此，嗯，作为回报，你知道的，你支持我，嗯，我为你管理这座城市。因此克里斯提尼发现自己同时受到克里昂米尼和伊萨戈拉斯的威胁，于是他加大了赌注。因此在公元前507年，他公开转向广大人民寻求支持。他基本上向他们提出了这种
of revolutionary new state that power should absolutely be vested with the demos, that it should be a democratia, a democracy. And this is a program so startling, so radical, that it's essentially without precedent. It seems to completely thrill the mass of the people who have been given this chance, even as it appalls Isagoras and Cleomenes. Isagoras appeals to Cleomenes, you've got to come and sort this out. Summer of 507, a herald from Sparta arrives, says that Cleisthenes should be expelled because of this ancient outmining curse. Cleisthenes gets the message, thinks, shit, Spartan army's coming. I better get out of here. So he scrams. Cleomenes rolls into town. He's very self-confident. He hasn't brought a huge army with him.
革命性的新国家体制：权力绝对应该归于人民（demos），应该建立一个民主政体（demokratia，民主）。这是一个如此惊人、如此激进的纲领，可以说是史无前例的。它似乎让获得了这个机会的广大民众欣喜若狂，却也让伊萨戈拉斯和克里昂米尼大惊失色。伊萨戈拉斯向克里昂米尼求助，你必须来解决这个问题。公元前507年夏天，一名来自斯巴达的使者抵达，称由于这个古老的阿尔克迈翁诅咒，克里斯提尼应该被驱逐。克里斯提尼听到消息，心想，糟了，斯巴达军队来了。我最好赶紧离开这里。于是他溜之大吉。克里昂米尼大摇大摆地进城了。他非常自信。他没有带庞大的军队来。
He occupies the Acropolis, meets up with Isagoras. They start to draw up their plans for Athens. But while Cleomenes is up on the Acropolis, he hears these chants, these shouts. He looks down. He sees that a great mob of people are besieging him, bottling him up, as so many people had previously been bottled up on the Acropolis. And he's forced to negotiate, he's basically forced to surrender. And Isagoras goes into exile, Cleisthenes comes back, and Cleisthenes and his backers are now in a position to institute this incredible experiment that Cleisthenes has been proposing to institute democracy. Okay, Tom, let's take a break. Clive Stenius has returned, dramatic scenes. He's going to start this extraordinary experiment that hasn't been done before. Well, we'll discuss
他占领了卫城，与伊萨戈拉斯会合。他们开始制定雅典的计划。但正当克里昂米尼在卫城上时，他听到了这些歌声、呐喊声。他向下望去。他看到一大群人正在围攻他，将他死死堵住，就像以前有许多人被堵在卫城上一样。他被迫进行谈判，基本上被迫投降。伊萨戈拉斯流亡国外，克里斯提尼归来，克里斯提尼及其支持者现在有能力建立克里斯提尼一直提议建立的这种不可思议的民主实验。好了，汤姆，我们休息一下。克里斯提尼回来了，戏剧性的场面。他将开始这个前所未有的非凡实验。好吧，我们将在
after the break whether there are other roots of it. But we will return after the break with a very exciting reading, Tom. Is that right? That's right. So don't go away. We'll see you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
休息回来后讨论它是否还有其他根源。但休息过后，我们将带回一段非常精彩的朗读，汤姆。对吗？是的。所以不要走开。我们一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐剩下的事》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
我们将揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告的音频、独家番外节目
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com. Your father, now that he had taken Athens, sat on the Acropolis, drawing up his plans for the city. But then he heard the noise of chanting rising up from the streets below.
并提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。你的父亲，现在他已经占领了雅典，坐在卫城上，为这座城市绘制蓝图。但随后他听到了从下方街道上传来的阵阵歌声。
Looking down at the entranceway to the Acropolis, he saw a huge crowd massed in front of it. At the sight of him, the demonstrators began to chant even louder, and to howl and to catcall. Your father summoned his bodyguard, but when the Spartans marched down the ramp to try to clear the crowd, they were pelted with stones and had to retreat. Then, abruptly, the whole city was engulfed in smoke. Fires seemed to be burning all over Athens. The smoke rose in dense black plumes that twisted and twined around one another. High into the sky they rose. Your father, watching them, saw how they were merging to fashion the image of a giant. Massive over Athens, the giant rose. Massive over Attica. Your father knew at once what he was seeing, for he had heard the Athenians talk about it often enough. He was seeing, black against the sky, the image of everyone who had
向下望去，只见卫城入口处聚集了黑压压的一大群人。一看到他，示威者们便开始更大声地呼喊、嚎叫和发出嘘声。你的父亲召集了他的卫队，但当斯巴达人冲下斜坡试图驱散人群时，他们遭到了一阵乱石袭击，不得不撤退。接着，整座城市突然被浓烟吞没。雅典各处似乎都燃起了大火。浓烟化作厚重的黑色羽状烟柱，彼此交织缠绕。直冲高空。你的父亲看着它们，发现它们正在融合，幻化出一个巨人的影像。这个巨人在雅典上空巍然耸立。在阿提卡上空巍然耸立。你的父亲立刻认出他看到的是什么，因为他听雅典人谈论过很多次。他在黑色的天幕下看到了
ever lived in Attica and who was destined to live there in times to come. Deimos, the Athenians call this giant. The people. So that, Tom Holland, that purple prose was written by you. So somebody is telling Gorgo, Spartan girl, who is the heroine of your book, The Wolf Girl, The Gods and the Greeks, or The Greeks and the Gods, I can't remember which way around it is, but this beautifully illustrated children's book that you've done about Athens and Sparta and so on. So somebody is telling Gorgo what happened in 507 when her father was besieged on the Acropolis
所有曾在阿提卡居住过、以及注定要在未来生活在这里的人的影像。雅典人称这个巨人为德莫斯（Deimos）。人民。那么，汤姆·霍兰德，这段华丽的辞藻是你写的。所以有人在对戈尔戈说，这个斯巴达女孩，也就是你的书《狼女孩》、《神与希腊人》或《希腊人与神》（我记不清哪个在前了）中的女主角，也就是你写的那本关于雅典和斯巴达等地的精美插图儿童书。所以有人在告诉戈尔戈，公元前507年，当她的父亲在卫城被围困时发生了什么
by Cleisthenes and his democratic radicals, the great mass of the people. Because Dominic, what's intriguing is it's not Cleisthenes. So Cleisthenes is still in exile. Oh, right. It's the mass of the Athenian people. So there is this sense in which it's the people. Because Dominic, what's intriguing is it's not Cleisthenes. So Cleisthenes is still in exile. Oh, right. It's the mass of the Athenian people. So there is this sense in which it's the people who are the key players in this process of revolution. It's like a scene from Les Miserables, Tom. Yeah. So the sense that the democracy is springing up naturally from the soil, that's a very kind of Athenian idea. They're very into the idea. And is this Tosh, Tom? Well, okay. So it's absolutely evident that Cleisthenes and his aristocratic backers, I mean, they are the kind of the key players in this. And it's evident that they're not motivated
由克里斯提尼和他的民主激进分子，也就是广大民众。因为多米尼克，引人入胜的是，这并不是克里斯提尼。所以克里斯提尼依然在流亡中。哦，对了。是广大的雅典人民。所以从某种意义上说，正是人民成为了这场革命进程中的关键角色。这就像《悲惨世界》里的一个场景，汤姆。是的。因此，民主是从土壤中自然滋生出来的这种感觉，是一种非常雅典式的想法。他们非常热衷于这个想法。这全是胡扯吗，汤姆？好吧。所以很明显，克里斯提尼和他的贵族支持者们，我的意思是，他们才是关键角色。而且很明显，他们的动机并非如此。
by belief that everyone has rights to votes or power or that a kind of shimmering notions of brotherhood with the poor or anything like that, that they're hard-nosed pragmatists. And their aim is the same as Solon's had been, to increase and solidify Athenian manpower and to try and lower the stakes for aristocratic players in the game, to ensure that you can compete for power and for glory, but not be destroyed by it. So that's the kind of the motivation. And it's evident as well, that the system of democracy that then gets instituted after Cleisthenes comes back, when the Spartans have been kicked out, that it's been very, very carefully thought out.
他们不是出于对所有人都有投票权、权力，或者对与穷人建立兄弟情谊等闪烁着光芒的概念的信仰，而是精明的务实主义者。他们的目的和梭伦的目标一样，是为了增加并巩固雅典的人力，并试图降低贵族玩家在这个游戏中的风险，确保你可以为权力和荣耀而竞争，而不会被其毁灭。所以这就是动机。而且很明显，当斯巴达人被驱逐后克里斯提尼回来时所建立的民主制度，经过了非常非常仔细的考虑。
And the whole system gets instituted with kind of incredible skill and brilliance, because it is a very, very complicated system. Because what Cleisthenes has worked out is that what makes Athens unstable is the existence within Attica of different clans. All these aristocrats stand at the head of kind of enormous great clans, and so therefore they can command the loyalty of these clans. And the power of these clans has to be broken up. So what Cleisthenes does is he slices up all the countryside of Attica, all the towns, the estates, the villages, into 150, that citizens of the democracy are obliged to take their second name. So it's not son of or daughter of, it's the deem that defines where you come from.
整个制度的建立表现出一种令人难以置信的技巧和才华，因为它是一个非常非常复杂的系统。因为克里斯提尼弄清楚了，导致雅典不稳定的原因是阿提卡内部存在不同的氏族。所有这些贵族都站在巨大的氏族的首领位置上，因此他们能够指挥这些氏族的忠诚。这些氏族的权力必须被打破。所以克里斯提尼所做的是，他将阿提卡的所有乡村、城镇、庄园、村庄，切成150个行政区，民主制的公民被迫采用他们的第二个名字作为姓氏。所以不是某某之子或某某之女，而是定义你来自哪里的行政区。
And the only way that you can be enrolled as a citizen of Athens is first by being enrolled within a deem. And so the effect of this is to completely kind of cut and slice and dice all these kinds of traditional loyalties and create entirely new ones. And aristocrats can't afford to be snobby about this because it's the people of a deem who will choose the representatives who go to the assembly. So if the aristocrat wants to be chosen as that, he's got to play ball. He's got to show respect to his fellow members of the deem. And so inherently, that then builds up a kind of a sense of equality of purpose. But of course, there's a risk with this that Deems might be used as a kind of launchpad for tyranny. So how do you stop that? So Cleisthenes has a solution to that as well, which requires making
而你能被登记为雅典公民的唯一途径，首先是在一个行政区内进行登记。因此，这样做的效果就是完全切开、切碎并粉碎所有这些传统的忠诚，并创造出全新的忠诚。贵族们对此不能表现得傲慢，因为将去公民大会的代表是由行政区的人民选出来的。所以如果这个贵族想要当选，他就必须合作。他必须对他的行政区同仁表现出尊重。因此，这从本质上建立了一种对目标的平等感。但是当然，这其中也存在一种风险，即行政区可能会被用作暴政的跳板。那么你如何阻止这一点呢？所以克里斯提尼对此也有一个解决方案，这就需要让
the entire system even more complicated. And I can imagine that listeners are cheering at this. So basically, what he does is he bunches the deems into organizations that are called thirds. And Attica has been divided three ways. And these in turn are then bunched into things that are called tribes. And so the effect of this is basically to ensure that you have people from one area of Attica are joined with another area of Attica and another area of Attica in a third. And then the thirds in turn are bundled into tribes of which there are 10. So you have multiple loyalties and there is no kind of obvious center for anyone to try and construct an equivalent of a clan. So it's a brilliant way of reframing and resetting traditional loyalties.
整个系统变得更加复杂。我可以想象听众们听到这里会欢呼。所以基本上，他所做的是将行政区组合成被称为“三分区”的组织。阿提卡被三等分了。而这些反过来又被组合成被称为“部落”的东西。因此，这样做的效果基本上是确保你把来自阿提卡一个地区的人，与来自阿提卡另一个地区和阿提卡再一个地区的人结合在一个三分区中。然后这些三分区又被捆绑成部落，共有10个部落。所以你有多种忠诚，而且没有任何明显的核心供任何人去试图构建一个相当于氏族的东西。所以这是一个重新构思和重置传统忠诚的绝妙方法。
And the question is, how is this going to work? And really, it depends on Cleisthenes convincing the Athenians that this very radical, this very novel, this very complicated constitutional framework isn't actually radical or novel at all, that it's simply giving back to them what they'd always had, that Solon had previously given them, and that Theseus had previously given them. And the way that he kind of institutionalizes this is that he draws up a list of ancient Athenian heroes, including Erechtheus, including Aegeus, people like that, people who had been involved with the kind of primordial
问题是，这会起作用吗？实际上，这取决于克里斯提尼能否说服雅典人，这个非常激进、非常新颖、非常复杂的宪政框架实际上一点也不激进或新颖，它只是把他们一直以来拥有的东西还给他们，这是梭伦以前给他们的，也是忒修斯以前给他们的。他将这一点制度化的方式是，他开列了一份古代雅典英雄的名单，包括埃里克托尼乌斯、埃勾斯等人，那些与雅典原始
beginnings of Athens. And he gives this list of a hundred names to Apollo in Delphi and Apollo chooses 10. So there's a sense that this whole system is rooted in the ancient soil of Athenian history and has the approval of the gods and that Cleisthenes hasn't really had anything to do with it. So Cleisthenes is not instituted as a kind of a Rose Pierre or a Cromwell or a Lenin. The memory of him basically gets occluded. It's ancient, it's primordial, it's ancestral. It's always been what Athens is all about, and it's God-given. So first of all, is this the first example in history, or the first known example, of a political transformation being rooted in a kind of invented past? It's such a common thing,
起源有关的人。他把这有一百个名字的名单交给德尔斐的阿波罗，然后阿波罗选出了10个。所以人们会觉得，整个系统扎根于雅典历史的古老土壤中，并得到了神的批准，而克里斯提尼实际上与此无关。因此，克里斯提尼并没有被塑造成罗伯斯庇尔、克伦威尔或列宁那样的人物。关于他的记忆基本上被遮蔽了。它是古老的、原始的、祖传的。雅典一直以来就是这样的，这是神赐的。所以首先，这是历史上第一个例子，或者说第一个已知的例子，将政治转型扎根于某种虚构的过去？这是一件很常见的事，
the Norman yoke in the 17th century in England, or the idea that the founding fathers of the United States were actually being true to a kind of Whiggish or post-revolutionary kind of English politics, or the idea that it's so common among reformers and revolutionaries that actually they're not doing anything new, they're just restoring the ancient liberties of the people. Isn't that what Cleisthenes is doing in Athens? And is this the first time it's happened? I think every ancient people do this. The Romans do it. The Spartans do it. The idea that you dignify radical change by saying it's a restoration of traditional ways of doing things. But I don't think anyone does it quite as boldly and brilliantly as Cleisthenes and his backers do on this occasion.
17世纪英格兰的诺曼枷锁，或者美国国会建国之父们实际上是在忠于一种辉格党式或后革命式的英国政治的观点，或者这种观点在改革者和革命者中如此普遍，即实际上他们没有做任何新鲜的事，他们只是在恢复人民的古老自由。这不正是克里斯提尼在雅典所做的事吗？这难道是第一次发生吗？我认为所有古代民族都这样做。罗马人这样做。斯巴达人这样做。通过说激进的变化是对传统行事方式的恢复来赋予其尊严的想法。但我认为没有人能像克里斯提尼和他的支持者在这次事件中那样做得如此大胆和出色。
Is this the point, Tom, where they invent or they institutionalize the story about Athenians coming from the earth and all of that stuff? Or has that existed before? Right. So I think that's absolutely the key question. How is it that this very complex system gets adopted so quickly? And part of the reason is clearly that it actually proves to be incredibly successful. That passage from Herodotus that you read at the beginning of the episode, that is celebrating the fact that the Spartans are unable to snuff out the democracy, even though they try to, and that Thebans get beaten in battle. Hurrah! The Athenian democracy has demonstrated not only that it can hold its own, but that actually it can go on the attack. So there's a slight sense there of, you remember
汤姆，这就是他们发明或制度化关于雅典人从土地中诞生诸如此类的故事的时刻吗？还是说这以前就存在了？对。所以我认为这绝对是核心问题。这个非常复杂的系统是如何如此迅速地被采纳的？部分原因显然是它实际上被证明是极其成功的。你在本集开头读的那段希罗多德的文字，它在庆祝斯巴达人无法扑灭民主，尽管他们竭尽全力，而且底比斯人在战斗中被击败。万岁！雅典民主不仅证明了它能够立足，而且实际上它能够发起进攻。所以这里有一种隐约的感觉，你还记得
Goethe looking at the victorious armies of the French Revolution and thinking, you know, new forces have been unleashed by this process. But there is no celebration of the fact that this is new. That's the whole point. And so the question then is, is Cleisthenes and everybody making this idea that the Athenians are autochthonous, that they're sprung from the soil up to kind of justify it? Or is he going with the grain of things that the Athenians already believed? And it's obviously quite difficult to do that because our sources are so scanty. so long. Not much before that, we have archaeology that does show that in, say, the 9th century, divisions between rich and poor in Attica are growing much stronger. But all the stuff about Theseus and Erechtheus, I mean, this is clearly not true. So where is it coming from? And I think that the difficulty that historians have in making sense of this is precisely that, what I was saying at the beginning of this episode,
歌德看着法国大革命胜利的军队时想到的，你知道，这个过程释放出了新的力量。但这里并没有庆祝这是一个新事物。这才是重点所在。所以问题就在于，克里斯提尼和所有人制造“雅典人是本土诞生的、他们是从土壤中生长出来的”这种想法，是为了将其合理化吗？还是说他只是顺应了雅典人已经相信的东西？要做到这一点显然相当困难，因为我们的资料太匮乏了。太久远了。在此之前不久，我们确实有考古证据表明，比如在公元9世纪，阿提卡贫富之间的分化正在变得越来越强烈。但所有关于忒修斯和埃里克托尼乌斯的东西，我的意思是，这显然不是真的。那它是从哪里来的？我认为历史学家在理解这一点时所遇到的困难恰恰在于，我在本集开头所说的，
that it's difficult for us to get back into a mindset where we can have any sense of what Deimos meant to the Athenians. Because it's not the people in the way that we might use it today, the people's party or the people's choice or the people say this. It's much, much weirder, I think, than that. It always is with you, Tom. It's never less weird. I pine. I look forward to the day when you do an episode and you say, the true story is much less strange
对我们来说很难回到那样一种心态中，去理解“德莫斯”（人民）对雅典人到底意味着什么。因为它不是我们今天可能会使用的那种“人民”，比如人民党、人民的选择或人民如是说。我认为，它比那要诡异得多。你总是这样，汤姆。它从来没有不诡异过。我很期盼。我期待着有那么一天，你做了一期节目然后说：“真实的故事其实没有那么奇怪，
and in no way weird. So this is one of the key reasons why I ended up writing Dominion, was the difficulty of getting to grips with what Deimos actually meant to the Athenians, because the whole idea that it's rights-based is an absolute nonsense. But what does Deimos mean? And the reason why it's hard for us to get back into and kind of understand it is that we don't believe in the Greek gods. And we don't believe in the fact that there might be a kind of, dare I say, a sacral ecosystem in which the gods and the land and the people are kind of bound together. And in which Athena, who is a virgin, is also a mother and a queen and a guardian and that this is somehow to the athenians kind of real
而且一点也不诡异。”所以这也是我最终写《统治》的关键原因之一，那就是很难弄懂“德莫斯”对雅典人到底意味着什么，因为整套基于权利的理念简直是一派胡言。但“德莫斯”到底是什么意思？我们很难回过头去理解它的原因在于，我们不相信希腊神明。而且我们不相信可能存在某种——我敢说——神圣的生态系统，在这个系统中，神明、土地和人民是结合在一起的。在这个系统中，身为处女的雅典娜同时也是母亲、女王和守护者，而对雅典人来说，这在某种程度上是真实的，
and so that passage that that you read from the children's book i think i think in that book i get closer to it than i did in persian fire actually yeah because i think that the demos is it's the entirety of all the people in athens who have, who are living, and who will be born in the future. Very Burkean idea there, Tom. Kind of. It's absolutely distinct from the flesh and blood Athenians who are going to the assembly or whatever. It's more spiritual than that. Yeah. But even spiritual is the wrong word. We don't really have the vocabulary to describe it.
所以你从那本儿童读物中读到的那段话，我想我在那本书中比在《波斯之火》中更接近它的本质，真的。是的，因为我认为“德莫斯”是雅典所有人的整体，包括那些正在活着的人，以及未来将会出生的人。这是一个非常伯克式的观点，汤姆。某种程度上是这样的。它绝对不同于那些去公民大会或做其他事的有血有肉的雅典人。它比那更具精神性。是的。但即使是“精神性”也是个错误的词。我们真的没有词汇来描述它。
It's kind of like the turning of the seasons, that every year the season turns and the earth gives birth to vines and to wheat. The same thing is happening with the people. The people have that kind of relationship to the soil. And I think the thing that illustrates this most interestingly is what the attitude of the democracy is to women, because it's the role of women that is traditionally the most controversial. It's the thing that people always fix on, our women didn't have the vote. And it's often said that women didn't rank as citizens in the democracy, but this isn't true. So polites is the Greek word for citizen,
它有点像季节的更替，每年季节都在更替，大地孕育出葡萄藤和小麦。同样的事情也正在人民身上发生。人民与土壤有着那种关系。我认为最有趣地说明这一点的是民主制度对女性的态度，因为女性的角色历来是最具争议的。这是人们总是纠结的事情，我们的女性没有投票权。人们经常说，在民主制度中，女性不被列为公民，但这不是真的。所以“波利特斯”（polites）是公民的希腊语词汇，
but there is politis, which is the female form of it. So there is absolutely a sense that women are kind of citizens as well. And you say, but they're not citizens, they don't have the vote. They don't have the vote, but they still have a role that in the opinion of the Athenians is just as important as that of the men. So the men have the vote because it is their responsibility to draw up the laws and to fight. That's their role. Their role is to deal with the affairs of man, to keep the democracy functioning in terms of state relations, relations with enemies, rebuilding allowances, taking measures that will keep the democracy functioning. But the role of women is just as important because without children, there is no demos.
但有“波利蒂斯”（politis），这是它的女性形式。所以绝对有一种感觉，即女性在某种程度上也是公民。你会说，但她们不是公民，她们没有投票权。她们没有投票权，但她们仍然肩负着一个在雅典人看来与男性同样重要的角色。所以男性有投票权，因为制定法律和战斗是他们的责任。这就是他们的角色。他们的角色是处理人类的事务，在国家关系、与敌人的关系、重建津贴、采取维持民主运转的措施等方面保持民主制度的运转。但女性的角色同样重要，因为没有孩子，就没有“德莫斯”。
And so the legal definition of an Athenian is someone who is born from a male and a female Athenian. And so the womb of an Athenian woman, it's a kind of simulacrum of the soil of Attica. It's where the Deimos springs from. Women are the closest approximation to the sacred earth of Attica. And that may not impress people today, but to the Athenians, I think it gave to women a sense of uncanniness. And that sense of uncanniness is heightened by the fact that it is basically women rather than men who have responsibility for the dimension of the supernatural, for keeping the demos in balance with the dimension of the gods. And so the Panathenaia, which the Athenians traced back to the time of Theseus and then
因此，雅典人的法律定义是由雅典男女生下来的人。所以雅典女性的子宫，是阿提卡土地的一种拟像。“德莫斯”正是从那里涌现出来的。女性是最接近阿提卡神圣土地的存在。这在今天可能不会给人们留下什么深刻印象，但对雅典人来说，我认为这赋予了女性一种神秘感。而这种神秘感由于以下事实而加剧：基本上是女性而不是男性负有处理超自然维度的责任，负有使“德莫斯”与神明维度保持平衡的责任。因此，泛雅典娜节，雅典人将之追溯到忒修斯时代，然后
ultimately back to Erechtheus, the founder of Athens. It's women who take the lead role in this. They are the people who stand at the head of the procession. They are the ones who weave this great robe, which every four years is taken up and adorns the statue of Athena on the top of the Acropolis. It's women who have responsibility for the cult of Erechtheus, say, on the Acropolis. And you may say, well, this is all just flim-flam and mumbo-jumbo. But the thing is, it isn't. Okay, so just to jump in and anticipate what some of the listeners may think. So listening to you talking about this, saying, oh, they don't have the vote, but they do all this. So, you know, when the great controversies about women's suffrage at the turn of the 20th century in Britain and America and so on. People who oppose women's suffrage would often say, well, the vote and politics is properly the domain of men. And women have their own things, which are just as important. And let's not muddy the two. Women do lots of other... So in other words, they would make those kinds of
最终追溯到雅典的创立者埃里克托尼乌斯。女性在其中扮演了主导角色。她们是站在队伍最前列的人。她们是编织这件宏伟长袍的人，每四年这件长袍会被带上去装饰卫城顶上的雅典娜神像。比如说，女性负有卫城上埃里克托尼乌斯崇拜的责任。你可能会说，好吧，这全都是废话和迷信。但问题是，它不是。好了，我来插话并预料一下某些听众可能会怎么想。听着你谈论这些，说，哦，她们没有投票权，但她们做了所有这些。所以，你知道，当20世纪之交英国和美国等地关于女性选举权的巨大争议爆发时。反对女性选举权的人经常会说，投票和政治本来就是男性的领域。而女性有她们自己的事情，同样重要。我们不要把这两者混为一谈。女性做了很多其他的事情……换句话说，他们会提出那种
arguments. But you're saying, but there would be nobody, you're saying in sixth century Athens or whatever, there weren't women who were saying, this is all nonsense. And actually, I would like the vote. And the vote is more important than being at the head of a procession or whatever. Well, there might be. I mean, we don't know. So firstly, the difference between, say, the suffragette Britain and Athens is that nobody in Athens had any notion that a vote is reflective of a right.
论点。但你会说，但在公元前6世纪的雅典，不会有女性说，这全都是胡说八道，实际上，我想要投票。而且投票比带头游行之类的更重要。嗯，可能会有。我的意思是，我们不知道。所以首先，比如说，英国的妇女参政权论者与雅典之间的区别在于，雅典没有任何人认为投票反映了一种权利。
I mean, that's what we've been saying throughout. That's not what has motivated it. And so that's not what's going on. And secondly, people in Edwardian Britain might turn around and say, oh, well, you know, the home is the proper sphere of a woman. That's just as important. But that's not giving to women the incredibly potent role that the Athenians understand women as playing. Because women, by
我的意思是，这就是我们一直以来在说的。这并不是动机所在。所以情况并非如此。其次，爱德华时代的英国人可能会回过头来说，哦，你知道，家庭才是女性的合适领域。那同样重要。但这并没有赋予女性那种雅典人所理解的、女性所扮演的极其强大的角色。因为女性，通过
basically negotiating with the gods, the protection of the gods, it's kind of like an insurance policy. And things have to be done correctly. The correct rituals have to be carried out. The gods have to be kept happy. And if they're not, then the democracy will collapse and Athens will collapse. And so men are engaged in dealing with the Thebans and the Spartans, and women are engaged in taking robes up to Athena on the Acropolis or going to Browron, a temple of Artemis on the coast, and doing rituals there. Many people who are very young, so girls, before they hit puberty, go out there and it's said, turn into bears. And that's one of the things that happens in my book. And again, I think writing for children, you can make this kind of stuff much
基本上与神明谈判、争取神明的保护，这有点像一份保险。事情必须做得正确。必须进行正确的仪式。必须让神明保持高兴。如果不是这样，那么民主就会崩溃，雅典就会崩溃。所以男性忙于应付底比斯人和斯巴达人，而女性则忙于把长袍带到卫城的雅典娜那里，或者去海岸边的阿尔忒弥斯神庙布劳隆并在那里举行仪式。许多非常年轻的人，也就是女孩，在她们进入青春期之前去到那里，据说会变成熊。这也是我书中的情节之一。再说一次，我认为为儿童写作时，你可以让这种事情变得更加
more vivid because you can say that this actually happens, that the gods do actually exist. And then the moment you accept that the gods do exist, then the jeopardy becomes that much greater. I think because we don't believe in the gods, but not just that we don't believe in gods, but we don't have the mindset that enables us to understand what it is to exist in the gods, but not just that we don't believe in gods, but we don't have the mindset that enables us to understand what it is to exist in the late sixth century and exist in a world where the dimension of the divine and the supernatural is all around you and has to be negotiated. Yeah. Because there'll be people listening to this who still will be saying, but the gods didn't exist. The roles that were given to women were nonsense. They should have had the votes. It's a disgrace. I suppose you're saying it's an unsatisfying
生动，因为你可以说这确实发生了，神明确实存在。然后，一旦你接受神明确实存在，那么这种危险性就会大得多。我认为，因为我们不相信神明，不仅是我们不相信神明，而是我们没有那种能够让我们理解在公元6世纪生存、在一个神明和超自然维度无处不在且必须与之谈判的世界中生存是什么感觉的心态。是的。因为听这个节目的人中依然会有人说，但神明并不存在。赋予女性的角色是无稽之谈。她们本该拥有投票权。这真是耻辱。我想你的意思是，如果你继续、如果你坚持强行带入你的21世纪心态，那么试图理解6世纪的世界就是一种令人不满意且
and ultimately fruitless way to try and understand the world of the sixth century if you continue to, if you insist on asserting your 21st century mindset. If you think of looking through a glass darkly back at back at this ancient and obscure period, there are two great smears of dirt across the glass. One is the fact that we don't believe in the gods anymore, and increasingly people don't have a very materialist approach. The whole essence of writing history is fundamentally materialist. We don't say, this happened because the gods wanted it to happen or whatever. Historians who are writing, say, at universities or whatever, are entirely materialist in their approach.
最终徒劳无功的方式。如果你试着透过一块黑暗的玻璃去回望这个古老而晦涩的时期，玻璃上有两大片污垢。一个是事实上我们不再相信神明了，而且人们越来越不具备一种非常唯物主义的方法。写作历史的整个本质从根本上说是唯物主义的。我们不会说，发生这件事是因为神明希望它发生之类的话。在大学或其他地方写作的历史学家，他们的思维方法完全是唯物主义的。
And the second smear of dirt across the glass is this kind of Christian idea that every individual has a value by virtue of being created in the image of God. And that is what underpins, I think, our ideal of democracy, the idea that people have rights to votes. But the Athenians absolutely didn't think this. They don't have that. There's a book written by a great scholar called Greg Anderson, who read a wonderful book about the emergence of Greek democracy. But he then wrote a kind of altogether weirder book called The Realness of Things Past,
而玻璃上的第二大片污垢，则是这种基督教观念，即每个人都因为按上帝的形象被创造而具有价值。我认为正是这一点支撑了我们的民主理想，即人们拥有投票权的理念。但雅典人绝对不这样认为。他们没有这个。有一本由伟大的学者格雷格··安德森（Greg Anderson）撰写书，他写了一本关于希腊民主崛起的精彩图书。但他随后写了一本更诡异的书，名叫《过去事物的真实性》，
which essentially is about exactly this theme. Basically how the entire structure or the academic structure of writing history prevents us from getting to grips with how weird it was and how strange it was. And oddly, it's one of the things, you know, that's absolutely one of the things that inspired me to write that children's book, was that thinking that if I can write an account of it in which the gods exist, in a sense, I'm getting closer to explaining it than I would by writing a kind of scholarly monograph that strips bare all the sources and deconstructs them. So it reminds me a little bit of, we had a guest on our podcast many moons ago who was talking about the Aztecs called Camilla Townsend. She wrote a wonderful book about the Aztecs called
这本书本质上正是关于这个主题的。基本上讲述了整个历史写作的结构或学术结构是如何阻碍我们去理解它是多么离奇和诡异的。奇怪的是，你知道，这绝对是启发我写那本儿童读物的因素之一，当时我想，如果我能写一本神明真实存在的历史叙述，从某种程度上说，比起写那种剥离所有资料并对其进行解构的学术专著，我能更接近对它的解释。这让我想起了一点，我们播客很久以前曾请过一位嘉宾，她叫卡米拉·托森（Camilla Townsend），谈论过阿兹特克人。她写了一本关于阿兹特克人的精彩图书，叫
Fifth Son. And there are passages of almost imaginative prose in there where she tries to describe their world through their eyes. And it's not very academic prose. You know, she's sort of, she's imagining, they're almost stream of consciousness chapters. Yeah. I guess that's what the children's book is, to get yourself into the head, which I'll just try and strip away as much as possible, all the baggage of a 21st century, fairly secular, as you say, materialist mindset. One other thing that people will say, Tom Holland hasn't mentioned, and that's because he doesn't care about them, slaves. There are slaves and there are foreigners. But I think the thing that's interesting about,
《第五个太阳》。书中有几段几乎充满想象力的散文，她试图通过阿兹特克人的眼睛来描述他们的世界。那不是非常学术的散文。你知道，她有点像在想象，几乎是意识流的章节。是的，我想儿童读物就是这样，让你进入那个脑海中，我只是试着尽可能多地剥离掉21世纪那些相当世俗的、正如你所说的唯物主义心态的包袱。人们会说的另一件事是汤姆·霍兰没有提到，那是因为他不在乎他们——奴隶。有奴隶，也有外国人。但我认为有趣的事情在于，
say, the emphasis that Athenians put on their autochthony, the idea that it's literally blood and soil, the idea that they have emerged from the earth, is that they never turn this into a kind of crusade. There's never a feeling that people shouldn't come to Athens because they don't share in this, like the Spartans do. I mean, the Spartans are famously xenophobic and keep foreigners out. The Athenians are perfectly happy to allow foreigners to come. They call them metics to live in the state, and they're perfectly happy to allow foreigners to come. They call them metics to live in the state. And they're perfectly happy to buy slaves. Why wouldn't they? I mean, slavery is taken for granted. Everybody has slaves. It wouldn't even cross their mind to... I mean,
比如说雅典人对他们本土起源的强调，那种字面意义上的血缘与土地的观念，即他们是从大自然中涌现出来的观念，是他们从未将这一点变成某种十字军东征。从来没有一种感觉，即人们不应该来雅典，因为他们没有分享这一点，就像斯巴达人那样。我的意思是，斯巴达人以排外著称，把外国人挡在外面。雅典人非常乐意让外国人来。他们称他们为“居留外侨”来国内居住，他们非常乐意让外国人来。他们称他们为“居留外侨”来国内居住。他们也非常乐意购买奴隶。为什么不呢？我的意思是，奴隶制是理所当然的。每个人都有奴隶。他们甚至都不会想到去……我的意思是，
it's kind of saying, well, why wouldn't you have a mule or a cart or a... Right, because they don't believe in human beings as being sacred individuals. Yeah. Human machines, Aristotle called them. But obviously, none of these people would have, because they don't belong to the demos, therefore, they don't participate in the democracy. Of course they don't, by definition. Can I just ask a couple more small questions? One, how does it work? How does the democracy actually, it is very briefly described what I do.
这就好比说，你为什么不养一头骡子或一辆手推车，或者……对，因为他们不认为人类是神圣的个体。是的。亚里士多德称他们为人类机器。但很明显，这些人中没有一个人会拥有投票权，因为他们不属于“德莫斯”，因此，他们不参与民主。他们当然不参与，这是由定义决定的。我能再问几个小问题吗？第一，它是如何运作的？民主实际上是如何运作的，我所做的事被非常简短地描述了。
If I'm a member of the demos, do I go and vote every year or four years? Do I put a thing in a box? Do I stone in a pot? I don't know. How would I do it? Well, so you have, I mean, it works in kind of various ways. You have an assembly where people absolutely go and vote, show of hands or pebbles or whatever. We talked about the ostracism before, which again is a kind of a way of decompressing tensions that might otherwise split the democracy so that if one person or the rivalry between two people two powerful people in in the democracy is becoming destabilizing the people can decide first of all whether they should vote to ostracize one of them i kick them out for a period of time and then if they decide yes, then they decide which of two people should be expelled. And all of this is aimed at making the demos kind of vivid in a political form.
如果我是“德莫斯”的一员，我每年或每四年去投一次票吗？我把东西投进盒子里吗？我把石头扔进罐子里吗？我不知道。我该怎么做？好吧，所以你有，我的意思是，它以各种方式运作。你有一个公民大会，人们绝对会去那里投票，通过举手或鹅卵石之类的。我们之前讨论过陶片放逐法，这也是一种缓解可能会分裂民主的紧张局势的方法，这样如果某个人或两个人之间的竞争——民主制度中两个有权势的人变得不稳定，人们可以首先决定他们是否应该投票放逐其中一人，把他赶出去一段时间，如果他们决定是的，然后他们决定应该把这两个人中的哪一个驱逐出境。所有这一切的目的都是为了以政治形式让“德莫斯”变得生动。
So politics comes from, again, from the Greek word polis, meaning kind of a city. So politics is a manifestation of the demos in the workings of the city. That's essentially what it is. Right. So a couple more questions we'll have a lot of people listening to this podcast i'm guessing particularly a lot of our american listeners who will think history the story of history really is the story of progress towards democracy you know if donald rumsfeld and dick cheney are listening this would be their sort of with their iraq war hats on they would be saying, well, you know, democracy will one day
所以政治（politics）这个词，再次来自希腊语“城邦”（polis），意思是某种城市。所以政治是“德莫斯”在城市运作中的一种体现。这基本上就是它的本质。好的，所以还有几个问题，我想听这个播客的很多人，尤其是我们的许多美国听众，会认为历史、历史的故事实际上是走向民主的进步故事，你知道，如果唐纳德·拉姆斯费尔德和迪克·切尼在听，这会是他们戴着伊拉克战争帽子的那种想法，他们会说，好吧，你知道，民主终有一天会
sweep across the world. It's sort of Francis Fukuyama idea, I suppose. I know I'm describing it very simplistically. Why doesn't this spread? If this is such a brilliant idea, why doesn't, well, you know, and also if it makes you better at fighting, why don't the Spartans, the Thebans, all these other people adopt it? Why is it that Athens remains an outlier? Well, two things to say on that. First of all, the idea that the famous Martin Luther King quote that Obama was very fond of citing, that the arc of the moral universe is long, but it bends towards justice. I mean, this is a very Christian idea. And so in that sense, the idea of progress is something that is a legacy of Christianity.
席卷全球。这大概是一种弗朗西斯·福山式的想法吧。我知道我把它的描述非常简单化了。为什么这没有传播开来？如果这是一个如此绝妙的主意，为什么，好吧，你知道，而且如果它能让你更擅长战斗，为什么斯巴达人、底比斯人、所有这些其他人不采用它呢？为什么雅典仍然是个特例？对此有两点要说。首先，著名的马丁·路德·金的名言——奥巴马非常喜欢引用——即“道德宇宙的弧线很长，但它倾向于正义”。我的意思是，这是一个非常基督教的观念。所以在那种意义上，进步的理念是基督教的遗产。
Not of Athenian democracy. Absolutely not. Why doesn't it spread? Because it gets weaponized by the Athenians, and democracy comes to be associated with the Athenian empire. Athens comes to impose democracies on subject cities as a way of essentially institutionalizing its own power. But the other reason is that in the long run, it is felt by the kind of people who write the sources that have survived, that democracy is a terrible thing. But actually, power should be in the hands of people who are qualified to use it, people who are educated, and that the mass of the people are just a rabble.
而不是雅典民主的。绝对不是。为什么它没有传播开来？因为它被雅典人武器化了，民主开始与雅典帝国联系在一起。雅典开始将民主强加给附属城市，作为本质上将其自身权力制度化的方式。但另一个原因在于，从长远来看，那些撰写流传至今的史料的人认为，民主是一件糟糕的事情。实际上，权力应该掌握在有资格使用它的人手中，掌握在受过教育的人手中，而广大民众只是一群乌合之众。
To be fair, that's what most people have thought through most of history, right? Completely. And so the collapse of the Athenian democracy in the Peloponnesian War, and then again before the Macedonians, people turn around and say, well, we told you so. So it comes to be seen as an experiment not worth repeating. Right. So that tees up brilliantly my last question, which is, we now think that there is a tradition, a story of progress. So Athens, then there's that business in Iceland, England, the mother of parliaments, the United States Congress, Martin Luther King having his dream, that there is this
公平地说，这也是大多数人在大部分历史中所想的，对吧？完全正确。因此，雅典民主在伯罗奔尼撒战争中的崩溃，以及在马其顿人到来之前的再次崩溃，人们回过头来说，好吧，我们早就告诉过你们了。所以它被视为一个不值得重复的实验。好的，这就完美地引出了我的最后一个问题，那就是，我们现在认为存在着一个传统，一个进步的故事。所以雅典，然后是冰岛的那摊事，英国——议会之母，美国国会，马丁·路德·金的梦想，存在着这样一桩
story. Is there any sense in which we can talk of a continuity a living tradition that goes through history in which no so basically you're saying that people pick up athenian democracy later and try and pretend it's a model for them athenian democracy once people start reading about it in the renaissance and after again it serves aristocratic elites as a terrible warning of what happens so in uh in the 17th century, Thomas Hobbes says people shouldn't be reading about this because it just encourages them to have ideas above their station. And he's thinking specifically about the English Revolution. He feels that the example of Athenian democracy
故事。我们怎么能谈论贯穿历史的连续性、活生生的传统呢？不，基本上你是说人们在文艺复兴时期及以后重新拾起雅典民主，并试图假装它是他们的榜样。一旦人们在文艺复兴时期及以后开始阅读关于它的内容，雅典民主再次成为贵族精英的惨痛警告，告诫人们会发生什么。所以在17世纪，托马斯·霍布斯说人们不应该阅读这些内容，因为它只会鼓励他们产生超越自己阶层的想法。他具体想的是英国革命。他觉得雅典民主的例子
has fed into the kind of regicidal instincts of the radicals in the Civil War. And the same thing happens with the French Revolution, that conservatives feel that the influence of the study of Greek democracy on the French Revolution has been wholly negative. But as democracy in the modern sense comes to spread, so the understanding of democracy comes to improve, and people look back at Athens and start seeing it as a kind of shining city on a hill. You know, this is the great model. But this is an invention.
助长了内战中激进分子的弑君本能。法国革命也发生了同样的事情，保守派认为研究希腊民主对法国革命的影响完全是消极的。但随着现代意义上的民主开始传播，对民主的理解也随之提高，人们回过头来看雅典，开始把它看作山巅之城。你知道，这是伟大的榜样。但这是一种发明。
Our relationship with the past is always creative. Right. You know, it's a kaleidoscopic effect. In an era where systems of government have the name of democracy, it's inevitable that attitudes to the original democracy are going to change. But it's also inevitable that we will look back at that original democracy as a precursor to ours whereas in fact it's not at all it's something very different brilliant what an interesting note on which to end tom it's a fascinating subject it's all about because it's not just a the story of democracies it's the story of the invention of tradition the invention of ancient greece as a model i suppose which you know most people listen to this i think will still think of the ancient greeks as the you know the birthplace of civilization, a model for all the lovely things we have today. And it's fascinating to hear that in your trademark style, made stranger and more weird.
我们与过去的关系总是具有创造性的。对，你知道，这是一种万花筒般的效应。在一个政府系统拥有民主名称的时代，对最初民主的态度不可避免地会发生改变。但同样不可避免的是，我们会将最初的民主视为我们民主的前身，而事实上它根本不是，它是非常不同的东西。太棒了，汤姆，这是一个多么有趣的结束语啊。这是一个迷人的主题，这一切都是因为这不仅是一个民主的故事，也是一个关于传统的发明的传统，关于将古代希腊作为榜样的发明，我想你知道，大多数听这个节目的人认为古希腊是文明的发源地，是我们今天拥有的所有美好事物的榜样。很高兴听到你以标志性的风格，把它讲得更加陌生和诡异。
Weirdness all around. Before you go, one more plug, please, for you. This is very, I mean, it's very unlikely, very unlikely. So if people want to read a book in which the gods are real, Greece is weird, people turn into bears, what's the name of that book, Tom? The Wolf Girl, the Gods and the Greeks. Superb. All right. And on that bombshell, we'll say goodbye.
到处都是诡异。在你离开之前，请再为你的书做一个宣传。这非常，我的意思是，这不太可能，非常不太可能。所以如果人们想读一本神明是真实的、希腊是诡异的、人们会变成熊的书，那本书叫什么名字，汤姆？《狼女孩、神明与希腊人》。太棒了。好了。伴随着这个重磅消息，我们要说再见了。
Goodbye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. That's restishentertainment.com.
再见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听额外节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。网址是 restishentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。